this character the Grim Reaper is a full
cloth Sim dude it's not a very
complicated shot it's really just
rotoscoping through PS1 dude
so well done not a touch with CGI or
even really visual effects here I think
it's finally time
that we reveal to the world our first
full feature films
happy October Halloween time is VFX
artist react and guess what we are going
to be doing some spooky Clips so watch
out I hope this video doesn't get age
restricted because there's some gross
stuff going on here we got a lot of
great things like the day but I'm not
going to spoil any of it so you just
gotta watch the video Let's Do It Let's
jump in
mom
no it's me everything's okay
it follows if you haven't seen it which
you should it's incredible it follows
it's all about a mysterious creature
that follows people and it's way scarier
than that sounds it doesn't matter
you
are
TV it's like yeah it's a ghost SPD
[Music]
the problem is that none of her friends
can see the ghost only her yeah see
that's why they're all chilling uh oh
this is gonna get scary don't don't do
this warning it's time to close your
eyes
you guys should get in the water you
want it
maybe in a little bit
dude that was the loudest
I've never authentically heard someone
golf in a scary situation
the most audible I've ever heard
instead I told you you should close your
eyes
huh
here we go oh my God
that's cool
yeah I forgot about that part you know
it's a few years old it's a low budget
movie that was well done though yeah I
feel like the hair Shop's just your
classic like I actually have somebody
pull it on set and just paint them out
do you think she's green screened in or
is this a roto plate it could be a
portable green screen this is the thing
where you shoot them on green screen
right there on the spot so the lighting
matches perfectly you're on the exact
same camera it's literally a Flawless
composite yeah if you ever need to shoot
green screen to put something in your
shot shoot them in the exact spot where
they're supposed to be put in and then
you won't not to worry about any color
matching the main thing that jumps out
to me first is that we can see all of
her hair going up to the top without
anything obscuring it so they had to
figure out some sort of way to hold her
hair without fully holding it like if
you hold hair you got your hand around
it remember the tip top of it looks like
there's some like extended hair I think
it's a touch of digital cleanup at the
very tip where somebody's like got
something wrapped around it lifted up
yeah because there's still gonna have to
be someone there holding the hair
upwards whether it's through a raw water
literally through their fingertips and
they have to be removed from the shot I
do like the dedication of having the
chair become like a CG chair that like
hits something solid because you can't
just fake that you can't just like
artificially decelerate a swing
instantly the thing is it's a lot easier
to mimic that deceleration if you're not
holding anything and also he like lets
go after the impact so it's kind of like
he's like almost like throwing it in a
way I feel like the animation of him
flying off screen I feel like it's not
that bad I feel like they nailed the
timing of it at least and at least angle
because it looked like they filmed the
plate of him just kind of like jumping
backwards which is how I would have done
it with no money and just like rotoscope
that out and animate it off screen I
think that's exactly what he did his
shoulders Arch enough so there is at
least something of a plate of him going
it's obviously it's a composited like
throw but you know once again it's like
you don't see it in motion especially in
like the first time you see the shot
yeah absolutely yeah you see is
everything we're talking about here is
on the fifth or sixth frame by frame
re-watching yeah
yo costume interestingly cut right
before the actual shower lands on him
it's not a very complicated shot but it
pays off really well it's really just
rotoscoping you got a Clean Plate and
then you throw a sheet over a person
wait wait are you saying I thought that
was a class no that's a CG that's a GG
I
she generated images I mean it looks
like you just throw a sheet over a
person I mean you can you could be right
that could be Roto in fact I kind of
think you are you guys are like cloth
Sims and I'm like but why would you do
that you just throw a sheet over a
person yeah and you just use that
element and you cut it out God dang it
and then you just cut their feet out
with a Clean Plate
it's like imagine you put a blanket on
me and then any parts of me you see you
use a masking tool and then that's it
yes
I'll give myself a spin for that sorry
I just think it's funny how like when
you really analyze this stuff you see
all the shortcuts but when you're
watching the movie it's the last thing
that crosses your mind yeah yeah a whole
bunch of films need to hit this sweet
spot of like having impact and making
the shot like sell you on a story Point
while being as shortcutty as possible to
get there there's tons of visual flaws
when you pause it and you look at it and
I think it's a huge waste of money and
time honestly to make your visual
effects for people who go frame by frame
don't don't waste your time for people
who go frame by frame yeah just make it
so it sells for the audience and that's
it that's all you need
[Music]
yeah yeah this one's not quite scary but
in the theme of Halloween death is a
thing I wouldn't get that close if I
were you just a suggestion what is murky
oh Samuel L Jackson for some context
Samuel Jackson is like the face of this
movie he's like the biggest actor top
build and not even halfway through the
movie this happens we're gonna feel
about this
oh oh
screwed PS1 dude
solid PS1
graphics so I think it is important to
note that this was the hardest shot they
had to try to do for this and a studio
called Hammerhead Studio worked on this
VFX that's some coincidence yeah yeah
this is 23 years ago that this movie
came out so this is one of those shots
that I think works because it's so quick
and you're not expecting it but I don't
think it holds up to time I love this
like janky 3D model that's like
basically arcade resolution there's like
zero contact Shadows zero Shadows from
the arms and the water that kind of
stuff is the very first thing I noticed
and it wasn't like the shark whatever
that's cool but it was just like super
pasty flat unnatural human movement and
then also there too like how flat his
clothes are compared to like the detail
and patina all over the rocks and steps
that like that's really it like the
circus like the shark is fine the shark
is fine I mean it starts better too than
the the dummy the digital dummy as we
call them in the business yeah so when
they got this render done they were
actually not happy with it and they kept
trying to do things to kind of make it
feel better they added some camera shake
they added some water splashes and
whatnot but it was the stuff on the lens
that really kind of ended up bringing it
all together the water splashes on the
lens that's not bad yeah they think that
was the first time anyone had ever done
something like that and you know we do
that all the time now like something
happens close to the frame put it on the
lens
when it comes to early stages of
compositing you have screen mode or add
mode and they definitely took these like
dots they're like screen mode please I
need transparency and then just
brightens the background so all these
water droplets are basically little
exposure Pockets that just like raise
the brightness of the underlying footage
it's a little odd definitely like early
1999 compositing right there so because
it's additive like that if you have
something that's already approaching
like a bright white it's going to clip
it totally I mean admode is great for
like lasers if you really are struggling
to get your laser to look nice you use
the additive mode and it just goes and
it fries your eyes and perfect so to set
up this next scene there's a movie
called The Frighteners from an up and
coming Indie director who ended up
getting his big break with the movie
after this one called The Lord of the
Rings this is wedded digital's first
fully CG character
wow
[Music]
wow right
[Music]
that looks that looked freaking sweet
that's really good for 1996 1995. It's
Not only was this a long time ago this
was made by like a small handful of
people like maybe six or seven people no
one told them that what they were trying
to do was like not realistic to achieve
and they ended up having to literally
code all of the tools they used from
scratch and the guy leading the effort
on all that is none other than Matt
Aitkin who sat right where I'm sitting
right now a couple years ago no way the
mirror is pretty sweet but I think
that's a pretty simple visual effect nay
nay it is not
here's the thing the mirror is showing
the background image really cleanly and
then the Distortion happens meaning that
your digital reflection needs to be so
close to the real thing that you can't
see the seams between the two but the
colors match perfectly like you can see
the arch of the doorway okay there's the
mask Edge moving across the arch of the
doorway there but like you can't really
see the seam between the mirror and the
digital oh you know something I'm
noticing I could be completely wrong
here but I think we're seeing a limited
number of bounces on the reflections too
you see all those little black strips so
what happens with Ray tracing you have a
ray that goes into a scene and bounces
around but if you limit those number of
bounces it hits something then
terminates and so what you end up
getting are these black areas where it
just doesn't render anything it's like
bouncing off into a void and so I think
what we're seeing there are some void
Reflections coming through which is
something that I started discovering not
too long ago with my own experiments
with caustics when I was like rendering
out glass and whatnot you can see the
same thing inside glass if you limit the
number of bounces so that was what drew
me first was like wow that's pretty
freaking sweet and it gets crazier after
that this character the Grim Reaper
continues to be a character through this
whole movie and he's a full cloth Sim
dude like yeah cloth Sims weren't really
a thing back then apparently there was
like one piece of software that could do
some cloth Sims but it was very
difficult to use and they had to modify
it a bunch to like get their shots they
still are like most people cloth Sims
look at the lighting looks so good that
was the thing that impressed me most of
the lighting the compositing is Flawless
it's interesting how the Grim reproduced
has like black Shadows like there's no
bound slider really ambient light on him
and that's probably a really smart
decision because the film stock they're
shooting on also has like true blacks in
it as well yeah it's very high contrast
film like this shot here he just matches
perfectly and then literally disappears
in the Blackness getting colors to match
like this is very very very very very
very hard especially when you're dealing
with late film technology super early
digital technology color science has
just been figured out film density and
how to translate that into digital has
just been figured out like this is
insane I feel like this movie is the
epitome of clever clever visual effects
in a day and age where those were not
easy to do and this was coming from a
team that no one had ever heard of
before so this kind of came out of the
blue and blew everyone away this is the
movie that got Lord of the Rings made
this was their calling card to be like
hey this is what we are capable here at
WETA this is what I am capable as Peter
Jackson the ambition of this movie the
fact that they were able to get it done
on time all of that stuff basically
convinced the network to be like all
right make Lord of the Rings all three
movies at once massive budget here you
go and single-handedly created a visual
effects industry in New Zealand what
would Halloween be if it weren't for the
kids right you know we got all these
gory movies like you know we got Saul
for adults we got somebody seagulls
people love it right but will anybody
think of the children well we did we
thought of the children we thought they
would love to have a saw made just for
themselves we made it rated G so you can
check out the Rated G version of Saw on
our Channel tomorrow subscribe it's not
rated PG it's rated G ready G for good
little girls and boys
so Ridley Scott directed the first alien
and this is alien 2 called aliens
directed by James Cameron I hope he
comes on the show someday dude don't get
my hopes up
[Music]
so here's the thing to keep in mind no
CGI all practical can't exactly have
gigantic 12 foot tall aliens fighting
gigantic 12 foot tall robots and it
feels like it's that kind of crazy
active editing that you kind of get from
any regular movie where they just shoot
coverage right covers were like you film
the entire action from one angle and you
film the entire action from another
angle and you feel the entire action
from another angle and you just you do
that and you give it to the editor and
they just pick the moments they like but
it's not shot in coverage it's very much
planned because we're going from live
action moments to shots that are
literally dolls and puppets fighting
each other so I think I saw a couple
shots that may have been like dolls like
doll size miniature work but in those
shots I could also still see Sigourney
Weaver like moving her head around
anytime you can clearly see Sigourney
Weaver's face that has to be a
full-scale shot yes that is a full skill
shot but notice how like you're looking
at just the Torso of the alien like
think about articulation right you can
have a guy move the head you know he has
to be in there or even like a robotic
arm and he can have like an armor tube
being moved and you can Academy of
stainless Sigourney Weaver but you can't
get hips you can't get legs you can't
get walking you can't do that kind of
stuff so literally any time we're not on
a close-up and we're getting the action
you're seeing puppets so you can
actually see this doll Sigourney Weaver
it's the one shot where I could notice
that the the Sigourney Weaver was
actually a doll and it's like you can
look at how they're cutting on the
action how they're replicating the
movements and motions and how each shot
Tells A Beat of the story even though it
feels like it's just a chaotic choice so
it's like you're getting story with
every single shot but it still feels
almost sloppy and like accidental right
like you're just barely getting these
glimpses they just barely happen to
catch even though in reality it's a
hyper planned out meticulous scene with
a bunch of technicians doing very
precise movements so well done not a
touch of CGI or even really visual
effects here in this entire sequence
every once in a while
you know we we have to hold up a mirror
here you know we can't just talk about
other people's works so today we're
going to be doing a little bit of maybe
uh self dunking maybe a little bit of
patting ourselves on the back too I
think it's finally time
that we reveal to the world
our first full feature film we made it
back in 2008 is we didn't it's not
coming out now and we made it back in
2008 yeah no this is it's like really
old
[Laughter]
dude the comping behind the trees yeah
it was really hard to do what
other smoke do those lines yeah dude I
had no idea we didn't have look we only
had eight gigs of RAM all right yeah
eight gigs of RAM to do these
simulations in dude this is this like
particle generated uh Team effects yeah
no I meant but like was the smoke being
spawned from particles yeah as opposed
to just like a big block yeah
high intensity that's why the camera's
rumbling
he turned goth how did you do those eye
effects contacts you just had to wear
painful so those were legit like full
fun blackout eye contacts
I like that shot boom yeah night crawler
I wish we could have gotten a little
more ambitious with the actual like
shots there but the actual like overall
motion and animation is really sweet so
many shots though yeah dude tell me
about it how many shots were in this
movie we never don't know we've ever
counted we didn't have a spreadsheet we
just looked at the edit and we're like
what's the next shot we have to do and
we did that for a year and a half
oh you want to see those cool bullet
hits by the way go back I notice on the
pipe yeah by the way expert level once
again expert level isn't that sweet wait
what were those bullet hits then were
those tracked in were they there the
whole time I frame it those are those
are real holes that you just painted out
for the first few frames there yeah okay
and that pipe on the right is a CG pipe
it's no you can't slap them on someone
just wiggled as they got hit and also
but don't you like the attention the
detail of the first hit seeing how it
goes through it and the Sparks exit and
then you see in the background it hits
the ground I wasn't even looking over
there no but it's once again the little
details yeah you know it matters when
you're making a shot like this every
ingredient has to be the best ingredient
this was truly filmmaking boot camp yeah
I mean what an experience like instead
of having to pay to learn how to make
movies in school we were getting paid to
make a move well technically well
technically even paid we weren't going
to debt it was a break even I mean I'm
sorry we were handed a check for like 50
Grand and like like we're in college you
know and they're like you guys make
short films how about you make a uh
feature-length horror film for fifty
thousand dollars and here's the script
by the way I read the script as we're
driving to go film it
yeah
the script's being worked on right now
but it's like roughly it's like a Sci-Fi
thing there's an infection and we're
like okay
agree yeah so like where are we gonna
film this Canada so we start driving to
Canada and we get the script
I mean I made two thousand dollars
spending a year a half year and a half
of full-time work yeah same but I mean
what's whatever I saved up some money
from college I I was floating also we
are watching our guys's first movie on
some random Youtube channel no I'm I
mean I'm hard cringing this entire time
like this is tough for me
so we always talk about leaving comments
on our videos let's see what kind of
comments are left on this honestly the
animation of the darkness was superb wow
okay intricate plot with effective
misdirections holds interest and keeps
the viewer guessing great movie the
ending was good but sad to me though the
whole film was very very good Ace of
what
this is like the first audience
and it's like this is way more positive
than I expected when was this posted
like a few months ago this year let me
see more of these comments people liked
it they didn't think it was dumb right
yeah I've been like 14 years since we
made this but they we know they're all
wrong right
trust no one but your cat or dog they
can sense deception best movie yet best
movie yet
cool thanks Teddy
dude Movie Central is coming in with the
positivity dude these are Bots come on
sorry I didn't catch the name of the
High School drama class that produced
and directed this movie
on average pretty positive yeah yeah
super positive honestly like I guess
something about having those low
expectations unless this is very well
curated comments I don't know I'm so
skeptical for some reason
I'm not certain if they intended this
but after watching this movie I have an
immense distrust of big corporations and
military weapon design companies this
movie made me feel like the core of all
the crap of the world is Big Money
corpse Warfare weapon makers and War in
general
let this movie be a lesson to you I
think I finally
I finally feel like I've been heard
[Laughter]
years 14 years later 14 years later my
job's done so seriously like we made
this movie this was straight to DVD we
just made it and it went out there and
it disappeared and like we never saw
anything else from it ever again it was
a wonderful experience we're with a lot
of amazing people but that was it that
was the end of it you know it's like and
we went on to do our careers we did
freelance effects for like two years and
then we started this YouTube channel and
been doing this ever since like we
literally never saw people respond to it
so to see these comments is very surreal
and like kind of feels like that was my
career came full circle now so yeah oh
God I can't believe everybody in vfxrs
react is gonna go watch this thing no
like I'm not sure if I wanted this to be
seen but whatever you know it's
definitely I don't care let them see it
let them see it you still have the files
for the movie yes so can we upload the
movie entirely to the website right now
we don't own the rights to the movie we
don't own the rights through it we
didn't pay for we we didn't pay him they
paid us to
two thousand dollars written with money
like that there's no way we would
there's no way you could keep ownership
of it it's like
you know yeah you can't they that that
was our price big money speaks yeah yeah
we're not giving up rights
we're not giving them rice to this movie
unless you give us two thousand dollars
now and they did it and so
find it away yeah
the movie Central probably like probably
pay like three thousand dollars actually
so you know hey welcome back to another
ending of a VFX artist react video but
what if you didn't want to end yet
that's right on the website we have
extended reacts wait you've heard that
before what's the big deal well remember
the Tim Miller episode we had on YouTube
your classic 20 minute episode on
Corridor digital.com it was 55 minutes
long because a lot of you have asked for
us to make longer more in-depth versions
of these react episodes and so we went
hard and now our react extended episodes
are twice as long three times long as
the episode's here on YouTube it's all
the raw gritty knowledge that these
incredible professionals have joined us
on this couch are sharing with us and
you get the episodes a day early oh wait
did you know that son of a dungeon has
also completed its run and you can watch
the entire show oh wait crewcut season
three is just starting do you like the
office what if I told you that there's
basically the office on
quarterdigital.com but it's us and it's
all the crazy wacky things that we have
to do to run this business and make
these videos it's a perfect time to jump
in we got a free two-week trial head on
over to quarter digital.com And
subscribe today
we need more horror films to look at for
next year's Halloween leave a comment
down below to help us out for next year
all right what's up guys bye bye
sorry sorry it's it's I'm losing it yeah
I'm good on scary movies
yeah I don't really enjoy watching
people just get mutilated I'm not a big
fan either
me neither we're not really good
[Laughter]
we'll see you tomorrow on this channel
for saw rated G peace